therefore I think they're Chinese for
sure why and then they they put them all
together like this and they're they're
dipped in like chili oil like that like
them the mouth numbing once and they fit
it in their mouth and they chew on them
they suck out the razor clams dude and
it's like oh my god what is this dog my
favorite [ __ ] quick-cooking one dude
by the way is this one Asian channel
I'll send it to you guys later hilarious
cook is not supposed to be hilarious but
this guy cooks everything in a wok at
his restaurant but he literally has the
live animal and it's like the most
obscure animal ever he's like today we
have a wood rat running around and he
just chops up the [ __ ] live wood rat
no way why does the camera and he took
out an in newer videos he took that part
out because I guess it's too graphic
yeah but it'll be like the most today we
have a shearling stout scarecrow why are
you cooking these weird animals that
you're not supposed to [ __ ] eat it's
like it's a wooden man wooden man it's
the weirdest [ __ ] it's like today we
have wombat I'm like where did you
capture this he goes it's very
Australian been in my family recipe for
200 years it's like your family has been
eating one bath for 200 years you
[ __ ] sick [ __ ] just has an excuse to
just kill animals oh it's just every
animal that you think you shouldn't eat
he cooks it and it's delicious
apparently it's it's like it's all in
[ __ ] Mandarin and it makes me laugh
what's located I said Cantonese what's
the craziest food you've eaten animal
why's uh I think I had pig uterus before
which I didn't know those pig uterus
because it was like in a hot pot okay
and I ate it I was like it was a weird
[ __ ] and then like me you know inside
the the pig eating a uterus right now
bro and I called the guy who was telling
me what it was he was nervous to tell me
cuz I just ate this [ __ ] and here he
knew I was gonna hate it me is that you
know the part where the you look like a
clam on a girl it's like a clay you know
guy have a hot dog you have a taco
that's the way you come from this point
on [ __ ] [ __ ]
how about you with the crazies food I've
had I've eaten grubs like an Ecuador
like the long yellow like the [ __ ]
lame oh the one that just [ __ ]
squiggling and [ __ ] like it looked gross
how was it it was it was all right just
like eggs kind of like scrambled eggs oh
really
yeah pretty good it was a bad it's just
that it's just the texture and the fact
that you see it was wrong yeah wrong
wrong what's wrong with you I just it
was an Ecuadorian come on bears Kona
Hawaii cuz he was already prep from that
Dukie dick yeah yeah yeah take that
shoutout to the first episode shot for
the first time Dukey picked out baby I
have a mutant once you smell Dookie big
dude you're just like nothing affects me
a stay tuned for the divorce you guys
gonna find out about that it tastes like
scrambled eggs it kind of tastes like
scrambled eggs what then I tried fried
ones and in live ones
I bet the fry ones were bread no they
were better because it's we it is weird
nice little crunchy like we know about
you would you eat mmm
right a cricket you can't offer anything
to a conversation well you have my dad's
actually beat all of us never I never
ingested it so doesn't matter eyes look
dumb some of it all those girls in that
are Kelly take me to ingest it either
and you're one of them know what can I
say I'm amongst legends do I wonder what
happened mr Kelly got a hand at you you
would have had his way with you yeah
your brother's probably especially like
I'm gonna piss in your mouth you like
already done it about two years ago you
would know I know you drink piss before
thank you see I can see the only I can
smell it happy I'll be like all right
mr. Kelly let's do this that's like
unknowingly I'd be like yeah all right
okay that's [ __ ] disgusting you're a
weird guy man go with the flow baby
tinkle tinkle baby I do you like the
weird mukbang stuff I think that's the
part that creeps me out about what just
like the just like morbidly obese people
eating which I don't know I don't like
that it's technically like two years ago
that was be the pain that's why I'm
telling you in wartime he's snapping
like he likes for sharing he likes the
suffering element no it's not the
suffering it's just like it's funny to
see when lady was suffering with the
crab legs through
like it was bad I was like that was a
bad aborting video and I didn't get in
like melted butter the ashes you guys
don't watch waterboarding videos those
are my favorite videos no bases of debt
I know I said I don't edit my podcast
but we're gonna no we're gonna keep it
on actually it's a videos now because it
doesn't take much time yeah it's
actually pretty quickly use it lay over
the audio and you go done
you've never cut anything for a pocket
I've cut certain parts where I felt like
maybe you shouldn't have said that
because it's about their private life
like now we'll cut that [ __ ] but I try
not to make cut that's my only have one
camera come on man yeah I tried multiple
cameras people hated it and I was like
thank you because it was a lot of
[ __ ] work yeah I don't think they
like the jumping part it's too erratic
they just want to see it kind of makes
them feel like they're a part of the
room when they're just right there in
the corner mmm your opinion matters
reaching out for you your opinion man
speaking of opinions man topic of the
day ricky gervais saw me bang bang bang
bang bang did you guys ever watch any of
Ricky Gervais cease a stand-up yeah I
used I we were just talking about it
outside we're taught us all the one
where he did the Noah's Ark hey
everything that one mmm he talks it he
talked about like the Bible for like the
whole special and he just breaks down
like it's really funny I'm not gonna
even do it justice but I think it's all
you do no I want you to ruin his
stand-up please do it all right
my name is no I'm not gonna do that but
no Ricky Gervais is [ __ ] hilarious
like he's like a [ __ ] medieval pest
[Laughter]
I know I just have a couple of shillings
but please could you give me some water
that's good
you could have been in the game with
problems I would love you know what the
funny thing is I really wanted to be in
the game of Thrones but I'm pretty sure
I would have been like somebody's Asian
sex some random [ __ ] Asian guy and
Game of Thrones is like what is he hey
some [ __ ] [ __ ] creature eyes are
small because he's always looking into
the light let's review all of Game of
Thrones starting for season one go ahead
okay first season was trashed second
season not great number three the red
wedding
let's want to start a poppin baby once
you stab a pregnant woman in the fetus
that's what's up that's what I like Oh
no-holds-barred do you do whatever yeah
and they kept showing it like an Italian
chef oh wait ma this is finally
something my speed I [ __ ] let Jon Snow
was interesting Jon Snow's doe I that
way that [ __ ] [ __ ] and it was
terrible yeah it ruined the whole series
awful